other news now in Sudan's Army in the
paramilitary rapid support forces have
reportedly been holding talks to observe
a ceasefire during the Muslim raid
holiday later this month that's after
the latest truce brokered by the U.S and
Saudi Arabia expired overnight into
Wednesday we have our correspondent Eva
Morgan joining us from umderman that's
near the capital Khartoum so about
what's happening now that the ceasefire
is over
there's been fighting between the
paramilitary rapid support forces and
the Sudanese Army in various parts of
the capital here in the city of umdurman
we were able to hear Heavy Artillery
being fired we can hear fighter jets
flying overhead and the surface-to-air
missiles being fired by the paramilitary
rapid support forces targeting those
fighter jets overhead now in the
southern part of the city there's also
been fighting around the engineer school
which is a base for the Sudanese Army
and which the paramilitary rapid support
forces has been trying to gain control
of for the past few weeks we also spoke
to Residents in the Eastern parts of the
capital Khartoum they say that feisty
jets are flying overhead and that they
can hear Heavy Artillery now they were
direct airstrikes in the eastern part of
the capital as well targeting camps
belonging to the rapid support forces
people say that they were expecting this
they say that the intense the most
intense fighting between the
paramilitary rapid support forces and
the Sudanese Army usually comes at two
times before a ceasefire is due to to
come into effect or right after the
ceasefire expires and now that the 72
hours ceasefire has expired residents
are being advised to stay indoors to
avoid being caught in the crossfire as
the two sides continue battling each
other okay but what does the end of the
ceasefire also mean for people who've
been displaced in in westar4
displacement has been continuing even
during the ceasefire many people
continue to arrive into neighboring Chad
seeking refuge and they say that in the
city of Janina in West Darfur Arab
militias Allied to the paramilitary
rapid support forces have been targeting
People based on their ethnicities now
the ceasefire covers the entire country
so that also includes the Darfur region
specifically westar4 but people who have
been able to continue to report a
gunfire being heard they say that even
when they try to cross the border they
continue to be shot at by the Arab
militias who are backed by the rsf so
there people have not been able to get a
respite from the fighting now there's
also the city of towina in North Darfur
the Army has accused the paramilitary
rapid support forces of violating the
ceasefire on the second day and that
tens of people have been displaced as a
result of the rsf targeting the people
in the city so in the dark four region
people say that they've not been being
able to get respite from the fighting in
many parts thank you so much Eva Morgan
reporting for us from underman in Sudan
well the head of the un's refugee agency
has pleaded with countries ordering
Sudan to continue accepting people
escaping the violence at least half a
million Sudanese have now fled their
Nation
we are unfortunately gradually
witnessing the destruction of this
country
many of the neighboring countries are
very fragile and there is also an
element of insecurity that risks
spreading as a result of this situation
my appeal to all the neighboring
countries is to say I understand your
security concerns but please keep your
borders open because these people are
really fleeing for their lives